Guten Tag.
Karakulak ist mein Name und ich bin der Dienstabender Arzt auf dieser Station.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Miriam Räger.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Ja, okay. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen bestabilen?
Miriam schreibt sich M-I-R-I-A-M-M-R-A-E-G-E-R.
Okay, Frau Räger.
Wie alt sind Sie?
43.
42.
Und wann sind Sie? Genau, Herr Bohrmann.
Am 16. April 1981.
81.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 m und 65 kg schwer.
Ungefähr.
1,72 m groß und 65 kg schwer.
Hören Sie mich noch?
Okay, ich habe akustisch nicht gut verstanden.
Also, Sie sind 1,62 m groß und 60 kg schwer.
1,72 m.
1,72 m und 65 kg schwer.
65 kg schwer.
Also, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Frau Räger?
Was für eine Frau?
Seit mehreren Wochen habe ich eine zunehmende Müdigkeit.
Ich bin schnell erschöpft.
Ich kann nicht mehr so sicher gehen.
Muss ich immer aufpassen, dass ich nicht hinfalle,
dass ich nicht stolper bin.
Dann kann ich nicht mehr so gut sehen.
Manchmal sehe ich Doppelbilder.
Und im linken Unterschenkel habe ich manchmal
ein Kribbeln, ein Wieameisenlaufen,
ein Torpeitsgefühl auf der Seite.
Linken Unterschenkel.
Und sind Ihre Beschwerden plöstig angefangen?
Nein, langsam.
Langsam begonnen.
Sie haben erwähnt,
dass Sie seit mehreren Wochen Müdigkeit haben.
Bleiben Sie auch unter Doppelbilder sehen und Torpeitsgefühl.
Torpeitsgefühl im linken Unterschenkel.
Okay, haben Sie auch Kraftlosigkeit?
Ich fühle mich insgesamt nicht mehr fit.
Ich mache sonst immer etwas Sport.
Ich jog manchmal und mache manchmal etwas Krafttraining.
Aber das fällt mir jetzt schwer.
Das möchte ich gar nicht machen zurzeit.
Haben Sie Unfall gehabt oder haben Sie irgendwo gestoßen?
Nein, Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Und ja, leiden Sie unter Übelkeit?
Also ist Ihnen übeln oder müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, übeln ist mir nicht.
Ich habe auch sonst normalerweise ganz guten Appetit.
Ja.
Okay, okay.
Und ja, können Sie also,
wie soll ich sagen,
beim Belaufen,
haben Sie auch Schwierigkeiten?
Ja, ja, ich fühle mich unsicher beim Gehen.
Ich bin auch so mal gestolpert, aber nicht hingefallen.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht sicher.
Okay.
Ich fahre zum Beispiel auch kein Fahrrad mehr.
Sonst bin ich immer sehr viel mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Aber das mache ich jetzt seit einigen Wochen nicht mehr.
Also nehmen Ihre Beschwerden zu?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erkennungssymptome, wie laufende Nase oder Nakensteifigkeit?
Nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich oder haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ich würde merken, habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Ja, und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser?
Das ist nur Unterstuhlgang.
Den Wasser lassen habe ich bemerkt,
dass ich das Wasser nicht mehr so gut halten kann.
Gerade auch, wenn ich Husten mal Husten muss oder Niesen muss,
das war vorher nicht so.
Also dann habe ich manchmal,
kann ich das Wasser nicht gut halten.
Seit wann haben Sie das vermehrt?
Ja, auch so seit dieser Zeit, seit einigen Wochen.
Seit einigen Wochen.
Okay, einigen Wochen.
Haben Sie Probleme auch Stuhlgang?
Wie, also?
Ich habe eine chronische Darmentzündung
und da habe ich häufiger Durchfälle.
Zurzeit ist das ganz gut, das wird auch behandelt
vom Gastroentrologen.
Aber ich muss drei bis fünf Mal am Tag habe ich Stuhlgang.
Aber das ist nicht besonders für mich.
Das war schon mal viel schlimmer.
Okay, noch eine Frage, Frau Weger.
Haben Sie, bevor diese Beschwerden abtreten sind,
haben Sie eine Rötung in Ihrer Haut bemerkt?
Also wann der Rötung haben Sie bemerkt?
Also vielleicht vor sechs Monaten, drei Monaten oder?
Ich hatte, wenn ich mich da jetzt dran erinnere,
hatte ich vor drei Monaten, hatte ich einen Zäckenbiss.
Okay.
Das war am Bauch.
Links am Bauch, links vom Bauchnabel.
Da war so eine Rötung und da hat mein Nachbar gesagt,
mach da mal Betairisadonasalbe drauf,
dann wird das wieder besser.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe es danach eher vergessen.
Ich habe das gar nicht mehr groß angeschaut.
Wenn ich jetzt schaue, jetzt ist da keine Rötung mehr.
Vor drei Monaten hatte ich so einen Zäckenbiss.
Okay.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie wegen dieser Zäckenbiss nicht beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Nein, war ich nicht.
Ich war deswegen nicht beim Hausarzt.
Okay.
Ja.
Und Ihre Appetit, Sie haben eben, Sie haben keine Appetitlosigkeit.
Nein, nein, ein Appetit ist ganz gut.
Und jetzt möchte ich einfach Fragen zu Ihrer Krankenfolge stellen.
Sie haben eventuell, dass Sie eine chronische Barmensündung leiden.
Ja, besonders im Enddarm.
Da muss ich dann manchmal so Schaum nehmen.
Da ist so Cortison drin.
Ich habe den Namen jetzt vergessen.
Irgendwas mit B, B, B, so, nicht oder so heißt das.
Da gibt es so Schaum und auch Zäpfchen.
Zäpfchen.
Und vorher musste ich auch Tabletten nehmen, eine Zeit lang.
Aber zurzeit muss ich das nicht nehmen.
Ich muss zurzeit nur einmal bis zweimal am Tag diese Schaum,
den Schaum in meinen Enddarm einführen.
Okay.
Und außer diese chronische Barmensündung.
Haben Sie irgendwie eine chronische Erkampion?
Die Barmensündung habe ich ungefähr seit 10, 12 Jahren.
Ist die bekannt.
Und sonst habe ich seit bekannt ist das auch ungefähr.
Und zehn Jahre eine Schildrösenunterfunktion.
Da haben wir immer gesagt, ein Arzt,
das ist eine chronische Schildrösenentzündung.
Ich hatte eine Unterfunktion.
Da nehme ich aber auch ein Medikament.
Und eben ist die funktioniert die Schildröse wieder normal.
Also habe ich normale Werte.
Also wissen Sie die Namen von Medikamenten?
Ja, das heißt Jottyrox.
Jottyrox.
Und die Stärke ist 75.
75, Mikrofam.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Einen.
Morgenst nehmen Sie.
Ja, morgens halbe Stunde vor dem Frühstück.
Okay.
Und ansonsten haben Sie Erkrankungen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert, Frau Rege?
Ja, im Kindesalter, da war ich so 10 Jahre alt,
wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Und dann hatte ich vor,
hier lang ist das her, 15 Jahren vielleicht beim Sport,
bin ich gestürzt und da habe ich mir den Oberarm,
den Oberarm Kopf gebrochen.
Okay.
Ansonsten haben Sie keine...
Also ich würde dann operiert an diesem Bruch,
an diesem Oberarm Kopfbruch.
Okay.
Aber das ist gut geworden.
Ich kann das wieder voll bewegen und sonst habe ich keine Operation bisher.
Also Frau Rege, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allegien
oder Unfältigkeiten bekannt?
Nein, sind nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Und rauchen Sie, Frau Rege?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay.
Und zünken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber wenig.
Ich trinke vielleicht ein Glas Wein pro Woche.
Okay, pro Woche.
Okay.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Ja, vielleicht seit dem 20. Lebensjahr oder 18. Lebensjahr.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Erfahrung mit Dorn, Frau Rege?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorständig geübt?
Nein, ich meine gegen Kinderkrankheiten.
Ich lasse das regelmäßig im Rahmen von meinen Gesundheitsuntersuchungen
beim Hausarzt untersuchen und abklären, der sagt,
ich brauche im Augenblick keine Impfungen.
Das ist ausreichend alles.
Aber ich möchte sicher sein, sind Sie gegen auch,
Sie haben auch Zerckenimpfungen gemacht?
Nein, ich habe nicht gemacht, weil wir leben nicht in einem,
habe ich mich erkundigt, wir leben nicht in einem Gebiet,
wo es diese Hirnhautentzündung gibt.
Das ist mir in Süddeutschland, Österreich oder so.
Aber wir leben in Norddeutschland und da sei das nicht notwendig.
Nur wenn ich dahin fahre und Urlaub mache,
dann sollte ich das machen.
Also waren Sie schon immer aus Land gewesen?
Ich meine in sechs Monaten.
Vor vier Monaten war ich in Ägypten,
14 Tage.
Da hatte ich so zwei, drei Tage einen Infektmagen da,
mich hatte erbrechen, aber das war danach wieder gut.
Da habe ich mich gut von erholt.
Okay.
Und vor Regen,
ist Ihre Monatsblutzungsregelmäßig?
Die ist relativ unregelmäßig, aber die Frauenärztin sagt,
das würde sie jetzt nicht mit Medikamenten behandeln.
Ich habe keine Kinder, wir haben auch keinen Kinderwunsch mehr
und wenn mich das nicht sehr stört,
dann sollte ich erst mal so abfaden.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie regelmäßig
Ihre Frauenärztin besuchen.
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung hin
und habe das auch abklären lassen.
Aber wie gesagt, es beeinträchtigt mich auch nicht groß.
Okay, verstehe.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu jeder Familie stellen.
Leber ich Ihnen jetzt noch Frau Reger?
Ich habe eine Frau, die ist 70 Jahre alt,
hat hohen Blutdruck,
muss auch einige Medikamente nehmen
und besonders wichtig ist, dass der Blutdruck gut ist,
weil er hat,
ist bei Zufall festgestellt worden,
eine Aussackung in der Hauptschlachader im Körper, im Bauch.
Die Hauptschlachader ist so ausgesackt
und das wird immer kontrolliert.
Die Erststamm sagt, wenn das jetzt noch größer wird,
dann wird es noch größer.
Die Mutter lebt auch noch,
die ist 69 Jahre alt,
die hatte vor vier Wochen, hatte sie Eierstockkrebs.
Das wurde operiert
und wurde auch mit Chemotherapie behandelt
und bisher geht es aber da gut.
Und vor 15 Jahren
hatte meine Mutter eine Künstlerin,
die meine Mutter eine künstliche Hüfte bekommen,
weil sie eine schwere Atrosate
in der linken Hüfte.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester,
die ist 45 Jahre alt, die ist gesund.
Sind Sie gehiwertet?
Nein, aber ich lebe mit einem Partner zusammen.
Okay, Partner zusammen.
Was machen Sie?
Ich bin Busfahrerin.
Busfahrerin bei den Stadtwerken.
Warum ist es stressig?
Busfahren ist ein stressiger Beruf heutzutage.
Es ist hektisch.
Das ist hektisch.
Es ist herunter.
Es ist sehr anstrengend.
Wenn man früh morgens fährt,
ist es sehr anstrengend.
Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Beschwerdentstellung.
Also in lesse Monaten. Nein, darf ich nichts von bemerksam nehmen.
Ja, also, Frau Rehger, ich denke, ich habe alle Fragen gestellt und fällt Ihnen etwas,
dass ich wissen sollte. Ja, ich bin natürlich neugierig und besorgt und möchte gerne möglichst
bald wissen, was ich habe. Ja, also, Frau Rehger, im Moment ist es ein bisschen für ihr etwas zu sagen.
Deswegen soll ich erstmal Einbauuntersuchungen durchführen, um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Ja, es ist zum Beispiel körperliche Unterversuchung, Labor-Untersuchung und gegebenenfalls
Bildgewändeverfahren. Dann, sobald alle Befunde vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen etwas genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Okay, gut, das können wir so machen. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, bereiten Sie so ein bisschen vor,
die Vorstellung, übersetzen Sie die allgemeinen Angaben der Patientin in die Fachsprache, in die
Fachbegriffe und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die vielleicht zugeschaut und zugehört haben,
können gerne noch Fragen stellen, wenn noch nicht alle Fragen gestellt worden sind oder wenn etwas
umklar ist. Bitte. Ich habe eine Frage für Sie, Frau Rehger. Nehmende Beschwerden im Laufe der Tag so oder ist es stabil?
Also im Laufe des Tages nehmen die Beschwerden eher zu, also dass ich am Ende des Tages sehr erschöpft bin.
Und wie gesagt, das kenne ich eigentlich so nicht. Ich hatte jetzt 14 Tage Urlaub die letzten 14 Tage, sodass ich nicht arbeiten musste.
Aber nächste Woche muss ich eigentlich wieder arbeiten und so könnte ich eigentlich nicht arbeiten als Busfahrerin.
Ja, und sind die Beschwerden intermittent oder sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft seitdem Sie beginnen haben?
Was heißt intermittierend? Ich meine, seit die Beschwerden beginnen haben, sind die Beschwerden dauerhaft oder kommen und gehen?
Ich bin nie ganz weggegangen. Sie sind nie ganz weggegangen und wurden im Laufe der letzten Tage schlimmer.
Okay, danke. Ja, aber Sie waren nie ganz weg. Sie waren immer vorhanden.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen? Schmerzen im Beine?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht. Ich habe dieses Taubheitsgefühl in den Beinen, auf der Außenseite des besonders des Unterschenkels auf der linken Seite.
Ernehrungsstatus haben Kollegen gefragt, Herr Hayko.
Was für ein Status? Ernehrungsstatus.
Also die Patientin ist ja 1,72 m groß und 65 kg schwer.
Zum Beispiel Vegetarian vegan, Ernährung.
Die ernährt sich gemischt. Achtet etwas drauf. Sie hat mal eine Beratung gemacht wegen Ihrer Damenzündung,
dass sie nicht zu scharfe Sachen ist und auch nicht zu scharf geräucherte Sachen.
Das sei für Ihre Damm-Schleimhaut nicht so gut. Und daran hält sie sich.
Die Patientin nur Parästhesi gesagt, Parästhesi oder Lehm andere nicht gesagt, Konzentration, Schwiehe.
Also die Patientin hat berichtet, dass sie Taubheitsgefühl hat in den Beinen, besonders im linken Unterschenkel.
Auf der Außenseite.
Nicht bitte, nur linken Seite.
Ja, sie spürt, dass das rechte Bein auch nicht so richtig kräftig ist.
Sie ist ja unsicher beim Gehen.
Aber im linken Bein spürt sie dieses Pelzige, dieses Taubheitsgefühl, Ameisen laufen.
Das hat sie besonders im linken Unterschenkel.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen.
Können Sie die Visusverlust genau beschreiben?
Doppel.
Ich habe Sie visus verlust?
Frau Rehger sagt, ich sehe etwas verschwommen. Ich sehe nicht mehr so scharf.
Normalerweise kann ich immer gut sehen. Ich brauche normalerweise keine Brille.
Ich kann nicht so gut in der Ferne sehen.
Und ich sehe manchmal Doppelbilder, dass die Bilder so nebeneinander stehen.
Die Beschwerdingen gleichzeitig, das hätten wir ja gegangen.
Ja.
Ja, ich bin gespannt.
Könnten wir als das Geschebchen anfangen?
Ja.
Von mir aus gerne.
Ich versuche mal.
Okay, versuchen Sie es.
Sie haben das bisher sehr gut gemacht.
Dann werden Sie das Aufnahmengespräch auch gut machen.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich Ihnen über Sie berichten.
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe Sie in der Unterchenkel, in der linken Unterchenkel vorgestellt.
Die hat berichtet, dass die Schmerzen langsam begonnen haben.
Sie hatten keine Umfall.
Wichtig zu erinnern,
ist, dass die Patienten vor drei Monaten eine Zecke gewissen bemerkt haben.
Eine Zecke bis?
Ja, eine Zecke bis.
Ich habe sie nicht bei dem Hausarzt gewesen.
Außerdem klackte die Patienten seit einigen Wochen in Kontinenz.
Die Patienten haben eine Stresse in Kontinenz.
Die Patienten hat berichtet,
beim Husten und beim Niesen.
Das Wasser kann sich das Wasser nicht so gut kontrollieren.
Wahrscheinlich Stress im Kontinenz.
Ja.
Die Patienten sind sehr fieber.
Die Epithelosik wird verneinert.
An der Vorerkrankung leidet die Patienten
an Hystereitiv-Kolitik.
Hystereitiv-Kolitik?
Hystereitiv-Kolitik seit 12 Jahren.
Hypotheose seit 10 Jahren.
Und dagegen nehmen die Patienten einige Medikamente.
Aber die Medikamente sind nicht erneutlich.
Die Patientin hat berichtet,
dass sie einen Schaum nehmen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Bude-Sonit.
Was ist die Patientin gegen die Hypotheose?
Es ist 75 mg.
Einmal morgens.
Ist es eine reine Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion,
eine Hypotheose?
Oder gibt es noch eine andere Bezeichnung im Rahmen?
Es ist eine chronische Schilddrüsen-Entzündung.
Es kann ein Hashimoto tun.
Wahrscheinlich muss man davon ausgehen.
Es ist die häufigste.
Eine Immuntyrioditis-Hashimoto.
Ich fasse noch einmal kurz zusammen.
Danke, Sie haben berichtet,
dass die Frau Räger, 43-Jährig,
1,72 groß, 65 kg schwer,
seit einigen Wochen über Müdigkeit klagt.
Da könnten Sie sagen, Fatigue.
Dann über eine schnelle Erschöpfung,
über Visustörungen,
mit teilweise Doppelbildern, Diplopie.
Sie klagt über Schwächegefühl in den Beinen
mit Kribbelparistisien, besonders im linken Unterschenkel.
Gibt es noch eine Lokalisation,
wo besonders im linken Unterschenkel?
Ausser.
Sagen Sie ruhig lateral.
Besonders im linken Unterschenkel lateral.
Es besteht eine gewisse Stressinkontinenz.
Und hat die Patientin sonst beschweren beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, wegen der politischen Uxeröser
habe ich die Patientin über Diarrö wechseln.
Wie oft zurzeit?
Die Patientin hat gesagt, zurzeit ist das ganz gut,
3-5 Mal am Tag.
Diarrö ist zurzeit nicht blutig,
aber es gab Phasen, wo es viel schlimmer war.
Der Stuhl ist weich.
Sie nimmt zurzeit den Rektalschaum.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein kortisonhaltiger Schaum.
Ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Das war einmal,
wir hatten die Patientin Operation.
Einmal wegen Apandicitis vor 10 Jahren.
Im Alter von 10 Jahren erfolgte eine Apendectomy?
Ja, vor 15 Jahren.
Bei den Patienten wurde eine Hoverus-Kopfraktur.
Das wurde auch operiert?
Ja.
Das wurde auch ostiosynthetisch versorgt.
Manchmal wird das ja auch funktionell behandelt.
Manchmal muss das operiert werden.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten in der vegetativen Anamese?
Also, die Alkoholkonsum liegt ein Glas Weim pro Woche.
Seit 18. Lebensjahr.
Die Drogenkonsum auch.
Die Reiseanamese war unauffällig.
Vor vier Monaten war die Patientin im Übden gewesen.
Dort hatte die Patientin eine Sameninfektion.
Wahrscheinlich eine Gastroenteritis.
Die ist aber folgenlos ausheilter.
Was sagen Sie zu Familienanamese?
Bei der Familienanamese gab es sich die Vater.
Leider die Vater an Arteelehypothonie.
Abdominalorte die Sektion Leide.
Wir würden im Augenblick sagen, dass es ein Ortenanorismus ist.
Er hat einen Ortenanorismus,
das kontrollbedürftig ist.
Der Vater ist 70.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Er ist 79.
Die Mutter lebt die auch noch?
Ja, die Mutter ist 69 Jahre alt.
Sie leide an Ovaria calcinum.
Vor vier Jahren wurde die Mutter wegen Coxatrose verjointed.
Sie haben eine Hyftprothese oder Hyfttep wegen Coxatrose.
Sie hat eine Gesundheit.
Die Schwester ist 45 Jahre alt und gesund.
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Sie hat vieles bei der Arbeit.
Sie ist nicht verratet.
Sie lebt mit einem Partner zusammen.
Sie hat keine Kinderwunsch.
Vielen Dank.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Sie ist in der Corona-Krise.
Sie ist in der Diagnose.
Also ich würde die Verdachtstiagnose in diesem Falle einer Multiplensklerose oder einer Encephalo-Myelitis-Disseminata.
Würde ich auch als erste Verdachtstiagnose in diesem Falle äußern.
Ich habe Ihnen extra den Zacken bis angeboten. Natürlich kann auch eine Neuroborreliose die Symptome machen,
aber dass sie gleichzeitig zu Diplopie führt, gleichzeitig zu dieser allgemeinen Müdigkeit, finde ich, spricht eher für eine Encephalo-Myelitis.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch muss man daran denken, eine Neuroborreliose, ganz klar.
Oder Guillain-Barre-Syndrome?
Bitte, Guillain-Barre-Syndrome.
Ich habe in meiner Praxis drei Guillain-Barre-Syndrome erlebt. Das ist ja nicht so oft für mich in der Praxis einer ganz dramatisch,
der allerdings innerhalb von Stunden eine aufsteigende Lähmungssymptomatik kriegt und kurz vor der Beatmungspflichtigkeit dann war, im Rahmen eines grippalen Infektes.
Also der Patient hatte Fieber und zehn Stunden später sagt die Frau, ich muss ihn dringend besuchen und der Patient nicht mehr aufstehen.
Das war ganz dramatisch. Und ein junges Mädchen ähnlich. Meist ist diese, bei Guillain-Barre habe ich erlebt, nicht so schleichend.
Über drei oder vier Wochen, das geht oft schneller, sage ich ja.
Das ist ein interessantes Fall. Z.B. chronische Darmerkrankungen hat gesagt und deswegen sind es unskönigere Darmerkrankungen mit neurologischer Symptome.
Also die Colitis ulcerosa kann ja auch ein vielgeschichtiges Krankheitsbild machen mit vielen anderen Organmanifestationen.
Aber ich würde jetzt im Augenblick sagen, neben der körperlichen Untersuchung sollte man als bald jetzt mal bei der Frau ein MRT machen.
Ein MRT des Schädels und der Wirbelsäule der HWS und dann könnte man schnell sehen, gibt es Entmarkungserde oder nicht?
Was ja auch wichtig ist. Ich würde Sie ganz dringend neurologisch eben exakt abklären.
Gut, aber ich finde, Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht. Sie haben das ruhig gemacht und Sie haben die meisten Fachbegriffe sehr gut gebracht.
Sie hatten jetzt viel weniger Zeit als in der Prüfung und ich denke mir, das werden Sie gut hinkriegen.
Wann machen Sie denn Ihre Prüfung?
16. Dezember.
Ja, da haben Sie jetzt ja noch etwas Zeit, an der Perfektion zu feilen und dann werden Sie das gut hinkriegen.
Wo haben Sie die Prüfung? Bei welcher Ärztekammer?
Nicht zu gerade.
Alles klar. Wir können gerne nächsten Donnerstag wieder machen.
Ich kann wie gesagt jetzt im Augenblick nur gar nicht sagen, wo ich dann bin. Das ist aber spannend.
Heute hat es ja technisch ganz gut geklappt.
Ja, gut.
Ich hoffe, dass es das nächste Mal auch so ist.
Können wir nächste Woche zwei Mal Simulation?
Ja, wir können das so planen.